policía antidisturbios gases
lacrimógenos barricadas y manifestantes
estas fueron las escenas en italia el
lunes por la noche cuando cientos de
personas expresaron su ira a veces con
violencia contra las nuevas medidas por
la pandemia las protestas comenzaron
tras la orden del gobierno de cerrar
bares y restaurantes a las 6 de la tarde
durante los próximos 30 días como un
intento de frenar el resurgimiento de
los contagios por coronavirus en italia
en las últimas semanas aquí en la ciudad
norteña de turín un grupo de
manifestantes detonó bombas de humo y
arrojó botellas a la policía apenas unas
horas antes en la misma zona unos 300
taxis se alinearon pacíficamente para
protestar por las pérdidas económicas
por la implosión del turismo a causa de
la pandemia en milán estallaron
enfrentamientos similares y hubo varias
personas detenidas y en nápoles los
manifestantes clamaron por libertad
mientras marchaban a la cierto cerrar a
las 6 de la tarde nos quiten incluso a
esas 20 personas que quedaron y que
habían dado oxígeno para seguir en este
último período de pandemia una vez
terminó la última ronda en roma los
propietarios de restaurante se reunieron
en los distritos turísticos para verter
latas de cerveza
puesto que ésta debe dando lo que se
está viendo aquí es sólo una parte de
nuestros suministros que tuvimos que
tirar a pesar de haberlos pagado en
lugar de servirlos a nuestros clientes y
amigos nos vemos obligados a tirarlos al
suelo como lo hicimos en el pasado al
temerse cambiamos dictatorial al trabajo
las nuevas medidas también requieren que
las escuelas hagan la transición a un 75
por ciento de sus clases a distancia las
reuniones en interiores y al aire libre
incluidas las que se realizan por
motivos religiosos están prohibidas
mientras que los gimnasios piscinas y
cines también se han visto obligados a
cerrar